. Some really interesting posts popped up
this morning on the David Pakman show.
Read it.
I encourage you to participate at David Pakman
dot com slash.
Read it.
We are just 90 or so subscribers short on
the redit of twenty thousand.
It's free.
Subscribe at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit
user record 58 or Rick Hard posted.
One hundred reasons not to vote for Donald
Trump in November.
And in reading this, the point and they're
all perfectly good reasons, including Trump's
continued lies.
I mean, just to pick one thing, he said he
would release his tax returns.
He still hadn't.
Right?
I mean, just like you could pick any one of
these things.
The tariff with China disaster failed.
Coronavirus responds on and on and on.
There are people who are arguing that Democrats
want things to be worse for the next five
months economically and in terms of the virus
to justify removing Donald Trump and to every
single one of them.
I continue to say Trump could stop doing bad
things today and not do another, quote, bad
thing for the next five months.
He would still deserve to be removed.
In other words, as a person who cares about
others, I want the economy to recover as quickly
as possible.
And I don't want a single additional person
to die of corona virus.
And even if that happened today, I would still
vote to remove Donald Trump because of what
he's already done.
And I think that's an important thing to keep
in mind when these right wingers talk about
you're trying to make Corona virus worse.
To hurt Trump?
No.
The case for removing Trump has been written
already.
And again, as I said, if he solves every geopolitical
conflict and cures all disease in the next
five months, come back to me and we can talk
about it.
But just look at what he's done for the last
three and a half years that has that that
is a ticket to removal from the White House.
If I've ever seen one.
Also from The David Pakman Show sub Reddit
Karaoke 24 asks if Mitt Romney was to support
and endorse Joe Biden.
Do you think there's a chance Biden could
win Utah or is Utah too deep red?
I tweeted something similar the other day.
Here's my thought.
I think that if Mitt Romney were to endorse
Biden, it would force Trump to have to fight
for Utah.
I don't think Trump will ultimately lose Utah.
Utah is very, very conservative, one of the
most conservative states in the country.
However, even in polling now, it's closer
than it usually is.
And certainly if Romney were to endorse Biden,
Trump would have to spend money in Utah, and
that would be a victory because every dollar
Trump has to spend to hold Utah is a dollar
he can't spend in Wisconsin or Ohio or Pennsylvania
or other states that are more likely to make
a difference.
So I hope Romney does endorse Joe Biden.
I already talked earlier this week about how
some on the left are kind of missing the mark
in terms of interpreting some of these Republicans
who are saying, I can't I can't go, I can't
vote for Trump, I just can't do it.
So I would love to see it.
I don't think it gives you talk to Joe Biden,
but I think it does give Trump a problem where
he has to spend money in Utah.
A lot of posts.
I'm picking just one here, but a lot of posts.
Thrilled about my 35 minute interview slash
therapy session on Tuesday evening with streamer
Stephen Kenneth Destiny, Bernell the second.
Now, I know some of you guys may not know
who he is.
He's a figure in the twitch gaming community.
It also does a lot of political debates.
And here's just one of the posts about this.
David and Destinee should make a podcast.
That was some of the best funny content I've
seen in a while.
We should honestly have a David and Destiny
podcast.
They're both pretty funny and know a lot about
the issues.
I think there is a lot of demand for a podcast
on both fan bases.
Many requests for this, you know, for now.
It probably is going to have to remain a sort
of check in every once in a while because
I'm pretty busy with everything I've got going
on.
But.
Really do appreciate that people seem to like
that.
If you missed it on the livestream, we put
the full 35 minutes in your interview with
Steven Kenneth on the YouTube channel, and
you can find it at YouTube dot com, slash
The David Pakman Show and find all of these
discussions that you can participate in at
David Pakman dot com slash, read it or search
for The David Pakman Show in the Reddit app